quick look at our covid numbers  nevada's positivity rate stands at 11.5  percent meanwhile the county reporting  165 cases per every 100 000 over the  last week the number needs to drop below  100 for any of those restrictions to  ease up so the mask mandate  you can always scan a qr code on your  screen there it is right there just pull  up your phone open the camera boom going  to take you straight to a breakdown of  our full covid report on eight  8newsnow.com  and if you do want to get the kova 19  shot there are a few pop-up clinics  planned this weekend one actually  happening tonight at liberty park in  north las vegas from 5 to 8 p.m  another friday evening at mater academy  on bonanza near nellis from 4 to 7.